speaking
my constituents I understand and accept
that part and parcel of me being able to
do that is give all of you an
opportunity to ask me questions hence
been here to speak to you today and I
know you understand that I am heavily
constrained in what I can say I can't go
into any detail you also know my
position I set that out a week past on
Sunday I set out again outside my home
on Sunday just passed I respect and
fully understand the process that is
underway but I am absolutely certain
that I have done nothing wrong and that
is a position that I will continue
to maintain so that's really all I'm
able to see but I know you'll have a
range of questions some of them I may
not be able to answer in detail but I'll
do my best to answer any questions that
you have
I'm not going to comment on the police
investigation that's a matter for the
police
obviously you know it's in connection
with the ongoing investigation it for me
to go anywhere beyond that would be
trespassing on the detail of a police
investigation which I know calling you
understand I'm not able to do
by continuing your membership at the
moment when Hamza yusufas had such a
rough couple of months would it be the
best thing for you to temporarily step
back as some of your colleagues have
suggested well firstly I think Hamza is
doing a fantastic job as first Minister
um I when he was elected as first
Minister I expected him to do a good job
I wish he hadn't faced some of the
circumstances he has but I'm incredibly
proud of the job he is doing and I think
he's getting on with that on behalf of
the the people of Scotland
um on the The Wider question you know
what surprised anybody to hear that you
know I searched my soul on these
questions on an ongoing basis I have
dedicated most of my life to the SNP and
I don't say that to make it sound like a
sacrifice it's not been a sacrifice the
opportunities and experiences I've had
in return have been immense but the
interests of the SNP are as close to my
heart as it's possible for anything to
be it there may be an argument if I
thought that if I was to step aside that
you would all then accept that this had
nothing to do with the SNP there may be
an argument that's not the case but also
what that would do I think would be to
compromise my ability and my right uh to
assert the position that I hold
absolutely which is that I have done
nothing wrong but I will always consider
and I'll consider on an ongoing basis at
all times what's in the best interest of
the s p a party that I have given my all
to over almost my entire life and an
organization that for me is not abstract
it's made up with my friends my family
my colleagues you've heard me describe
it before as my extended family that's
the depth of love affection and concern
I have for the the SMP haven't you in
the past asked others to step back from
the party when they've said they've done
nothing wrong but you know that that
session has been made and you know there
have been some over the past few days
that have made their position clear and
I respect the position in one case in
particular I absolutely understand the
feelings that drive that position but
you're not actually correct to assert
that that was some iron precedent I can
think of one case in particular probably
the most analogous case to the one that
I am in right now where there wasn't any
demand or expectation for that
individual to step aside so I will
always consider what is in the best
interests of the smps I've said before
and I repeat I don't see it as any kind
of suggestion it's been a sacrifice the
S P's been my life and that's been uh
voluntary and something that I cherish
and continue to cherish but I'm also an
individual that is entitled to a Circ
what I believe to my very very core that
have done nothing wrong I respect the
process that is underway but I will
continue to maintain that very clear
position
you've had you've had a question can I
I'm going to take this question then
I'll come back you must have thought
about quitting I think about what's in
the best interest of the party I've
given my life to what's in the best
interests of the government that until
very recently I headed and spent 16
years either being the head of or second
in command and and obviously I think a
lot about in this difficult situation
what is best for me as an individual and
I will come to judgments people can
disagree or agree with those judgments
that is entirely out down to them I
understand some of the the comments that
have been made but I take all of these
issues and considerations very seriously
and I don't all shout at me once again
look I and before I say what I'm about
to say I'm seeing it as a statement of
fact not a loaded statement that you
should read anything into one way or the
other but in a situation like this I can
only speak for myself and I am only
speaking for myself there is also a
difference between me and my husband I
am an elected politician I'm a public
servant and therefore there is an
expectation I think intimate expectation
on your part that I make statements and
to the best of my ability to answer
questions obviously Peter is not in that
position
foreign
I've covered that uh and I'm not going
to say any more people are entitled uh
to that opinion I've set out as clearly
as I can at my position and I've been
deeply touched by the support I've had
from people I know from people
in the way to public that I've never met
over recent days in this kind of
situation I don't take that for granted
at all but I've been deeply touched by
it and given that I'm standing in front
of all of you in front of cameras right
now I'd want to take the opportunity to
thank people for that
I understand Michelle's position I
understand why she said what she has
said I right now I'm speaking for myself
when you resigned you told ITV users in
an interview that the last thing you
wanted to do is to be unhelpful to your
successor the day before his first big
speech and Independence is when you
decided to give an impromptu press
conference on your driveway coming out
to be a few years to go back home timing
is really crucial in politics which you
know well is there a part of you that
thinks that this circus now surrounding
you hardly you're engaging with is now
becoming unhappable firstly there is a
process underway that I am not in
control of clearly if I was in control
of it we wouldn't be standing here right
now and I don't say that to be
lighthearted in any way there's nothing
about this that I am light-hearted about
but Peter you you've characterized that
question there
um that suggests that I am somehow
choosing to stand before you right now I
well I am choosing to do it because and
I should say this is not a criticism of
you it's you're doing your job if I
hadn't done this today then I couldn't
have come here to Parliament and gone
about my job because I wouldn't be able
to walk through this Lobby without all
of you trying to in an impromptu we do
what has done I couldn't have gone back
inside my own house on Sunday because
there were members of the media outside
without stopping to speak or you would
all have understandably stayed out of
there so I am doing these things in
order to subject myself to the scrutiny
that you're all entitled to subject me
to as an elected politician and also to
try to give myself the ability
notwithstanding what is going on right
now to do my job because I have a job to
do on behalf of my constituents and I'm
going to do it
is very able to speak for himself on
this issue he has spoken for himself and
I'm not going to try it to do it on his
behalf Holmes is doing an excellent job
and I'm not talking on these matters I'm
talking more wildly I think Hamza
haven't been in the job for a relatively
short period of time is proving himself
to be a very very fine first minister
it's not been the best period of my life
Colin I think that is probably an
understatement it's not an easy period
but again I'm not saying that for
sympathy this is a serious process it's
a process that I respect and will
continue it to do so but I I don't think
it is perhaps the most difficult
question to be asked to say in these
circumstances am I finding it easy I
think the answer to that is probably
pretty obvious Mr will you resign I'm
not going to speculate I am the the
thing that sustains me uh right now is
the certainty that I have done nothing
wrong and I'm entitled it to that
presumption in law but actually more
than that that is a view that I know
it's not a view it is a belief in a
certainty that I have right I'm going to
take a couple more questions before I
pick up the garden Mobby
well I I answered that question at the
same I don't know if you heard it I this
is a statement of fact so don't read
anything one way the other into this I
can only speak for myself in these
matters I'm here speaking for myself and
I as I have done previously expressing
again my certainty that I have done
nothing wrong
[Music]
well I think the case for Scottish
independence
um is strong I think it gets stronger
every day I'm not here to engage in uh
well he can ask me political questions
if you want that's not the purpose of me
being here but I think the case for
Scottish independence is getting
stronger and my belief that Scotland
will soon be an independent country uh
is unshaken and unshakable thank you all
very much indeed
oh there you have it the former first
minister of Scotland Nicholas sturgeon
returning to Holly Ridge for the first
time uh since her arrest over the
party's finances uh wanting to come out
and address journalists so that
essentially she can get on with her job
she said she reiterated the fact that
she has done nothing wrong she says I am
certain I've done nothing wrong but I
respect the process but I know to my
core that I have done nothing wrong
let's bring in our Scotland
correspondent Connor Gillis who was
there and so Connor we did wonder why
Nicholas surgeon was calling this press
conference but we get a bit of
understanding now she's wanting to put
herself up for scrutiny in front of
journalists so essentially she says she
can get on with serving her constituents
yeah this has been a circus that has
been a long time coming many people have
been asking over the course of the last
week when Nicola sturgeon would come and
answer questions those questions that
you heard in full here on Sky News and
that was this moment this is her trying
to draw a line under that very difficult
period that she endured more than one
week ago when she presented herself at a
police station and subjected herself
under police arrest to more than seven
hours of questions questions focusing on
the snp's funding and its finances
questions as part of a police probe that
have dated back more than two years now
culminating in her arrest that has also
witnessed the arrest of her husband and
the then treasurer of the SMP she said
clearly that this had not been an easy
time for her she wasn't wanting to look
for sympathy here but when questioned
during that exchange over the course of
the last 20 minutes or so she was clear
that she is not intending to step back
albeit temporarily from the Scottish
national party the party that she once
laid at all she plans to stay there no
matter how much of a distraction that
becomes for the new leader Hamza Yusuf
the reason she says is because if she
was to take a step back albeit on a
temporary basis then that may undermine
her position that she is innocent of any
wrongdoing so this was Nicola sturgeon
trying to draw a line under this
investigation clearly that is continuing
police will be going over what they
learned what they were listening to when
discussing the snp's funding and
finances with the former first Minister
but this has also become an Almighty
distraction for the new uh first
Minister here in Scotland comes the use
of yesterday he was trying to re-change
the conversation change it back to the
main mission of Scottish independence
for the SMP and Nicola sturgeon herself
came out on her own doorstep returning
from hiding after a week to answer
questions on Sunday then again those 20
minutes or so that we heard from her
there so what will happen next well this
police investigation will continue
Nicholas sturgeon says she hopes to
continue on with her day job Peter
Hollywood Connor Thank You Connor give
us with the latest there from Hollywood
right let's bring you an update on the
breaking news we brought you earlier it
concerns president